So the Blackboard component is our equivalent of the behavior tree component for the behavior tree,
the Blackboard component is to the Blackboard.
It's a wrapper around the kind of core object,
so in this case the Blackboard is the thing that the Blackboard component holds inside it,
and it gives us a way to interact with that Blackboard from outside it,
so we can pass information in, we can query information out of it.
Just as an example if we were to jump to our project,
if we go into the AI controller, again this is the project you can download with this tutorial,
we don't need to go into this in detail at the moment,
I'll demonstrate this a little bit later on what this is all actually doing,
but if we look inside our AI controller when we perceive some actors,
we do a little bit of querying, we check if it's a pawn,
and then this point where we do Blackboard set value as object,
this is reaching into the Blackboard component on the AI controller and setting a value.
So this is reaching into our Blackboard,
assigning something based on world logic from world data,
and then it is assigned to the Blackboard,
and then the behavior tree which is linked with this Blackboard
can operate with that information,
can behave based on that gameplay change, based on that world data.
So as I mentioned it's strongly paired with the behavior tree component,
this is really obvious from even just when you go into editing a Blackboard,
if I go to find our behavior tree here,
and I go to our Blackboard,
well okay from the Blackboard maybe it's,
but if you go to your behavior tree this is linked with a Blackboard asset,
and you can jump back and forth between the two,
we've got the editor kind of like, you know,
really indicates how strongly these two things are paired together,
but even inside the actual code itself,
if we were to jump to our Blackboard component,
there we see we've got functions for getting the brain component,
we've got a function for caching the brain component,
so it very much expects the thing to exist,
and even inside our brain component,
I think it is, I don't think it's the behavior tree,
it might be the behavior tree, let's see,
behavior tree component.cpp, sorry,
and I think it's in the initialize component cache behavior,
or maybe it's inside the brain component,
one second,
braincomponent.cpp, yeah right there,
so inside our brain component on the initialize component,
it expects that, you know, whatever owns this component
also has a Blackboard component class,
and then it kind of assigns itself as the brain for that Blackboard,
so you can see how much these two things expect
to kind of work in conjunction with each other.
So yeah, in terms of the actual creation,
it follows a similar pattern to the behavior tree,
so you can already create one on your AI controller,
and then it's kind of already available
if you want the AI to work as soon as it's possessing an object,
and similarly, if you go to run a behavior tree,
what that will do is, as you've seen,
you can choose a default Blackboard to use for your behavior tree,
you can just assign the Blackboard this should use,
so if you were to run that behavior tree,
and the AI controller didn't have a behavior tree component already,
it would create the appropriate behavior tree component,
plug in this behavior tree,
and then create a Blackboard component
using the default Blackboard of that behavior tree.
So essentially you can create the Blackboard in two ways,
you can make it ahead of time in editor,
or you can rely on that kind of again created at runtime
by that run behavior tree functionality.
And then, oh yeah, the last thing to mention is just that
one of the kind of powerful things about Blackboard
is the ability for objects to kind of register themselves as observers,
and what you would essentially do is you,
Blackboard keys are again this kind of variable type,
so it represents particular data,
but it's kind of a struct around that data,
and you register yourself as a listener for a particular Blackboard key
to be notified when that Blackboard key has changed.
So an example of that is the move to execute task,
I think I've got that open still,
bt task move to,
and if we go to execute task,
you'll see here,
it reaches into the Blackboard component,
gets the memory,
gets the delegate handle,
and basically registers an observer like this.
So essentially, in this case,
it's the move to task might need to be notified
if the Blackboard value has changed,
either because the thing it's following has changed,
or if the actor has moved,
we need to be kind of aware of that.
And other examples of that would be,
as we've kind of already mentioned in our behavior tree,
we can have a decorator
that's kind of based on a Blackboard condition,
and so therefore this will need to register itself
as an observer of whatever Blackboard key we choose,
in this case it's target actor,
so that this Blackboard,
so that this decorator can essentially be like rerun,
can abort,
can do whatever abort behavior it needs to do,
can rerun to check for whether or not the result has changed.
So yeah, that's another place where this logic
registering as an observer will already be getting utilized.
So we've talked about the kind of behavior logic,
we've talked about the brain, the memory,
but one of the really key components to implementing AI
is getting the AI to move around.
Unreal has its own native implementation of 3D navigation,
which is the navigation system.
So the navigation system is comprised of a mesh,
which is generated in editor,
and essentially this mesh will query things about the environment
and generate a mesh either at runtime or editor time,
typically editor time first,
to basically do a lot of tracing and querying in a kind of geometric sense
to establish what areas are navigable and non-navigable.
It's important to mention that this is
particularly for entities that run along the ground.
So if we wanted something like 3D,
so either for flying around or swimming based navigation,
it's likely that you'll need to roll your own implementation for that.
It's always worth checking Unreal plugins,
it's always worth looking at FAB
because it's quite likely that something for this already exists,
but certainly the out-of-the-box navigation system,
the nav mesh,
is designed for along-the-floor land-based AI movement.
As I said, it already supports static and dynamic,
so we can generate this nav data at editor time,
or if we need it to be responsive to things
that are changing in the environment,
we can mark it up as dynamic,
obviously with a slight performance cost.
And then we can also use nav modifier volumes,
which can be used as part of this,
either statically or dynamically,
and these can incur navigation costs
if we want areas of high cost,
and they can also act as kind of blockers
to prevent navigation being generated around particular areas.
Physical objects can also affect this in a similar way.
Anytime you're creating a primitive component,
so typically a kind of collision or a visual mesh,
you can mark that object
as whether or not it should affect navigation,
and then that would be whether or not essentially
the navigation system should pay attention to this mesh,
to its bounding volume,
whether it should pay attention to it
when it's generating navigable space.
Navigation can be generated,
different navigation can be generated for different agents,
so we can have the idea of large objects and small objects,
and then navigating in different ways,
being able to negotiate different spaces,
a motorbike can get through a gap that a tank can't,
and so we can generate different nav meshes
to kind of like account for that.
We can also, just whenever we're talking about nav mesh stuff,
it's worth mentioning that we can hit P
whenever we're in editor to visualize this.
This is not when you're in player and editor mode,
or it can be when you're in player and editor mode,
but only when you're ejected,
so not when you're playing as a,
possessing a pawn moving around,
but you can just press P to kind of see the nav mesh
and how it's being generated.
That's either at editor time or at runtime
if you're in eject mode.
And also, yeah, we can form links
between different kind of islands of nav mesh
to allow AI to kind of traverse spaces.
This can either be from heights,
so we can, you know,
we can handle the idea of like jumping from a ledge to the ground,
or it can be, as I said,
through kind of areas of distinct space
that have been generated to kind of,
we can link them together
so that AI can traverse between them.
So as we've already mentioned,
we've kind of covered the kind of bare bones,
but just to kind of go into like actually
how we would do this
to actually make a nav mesh in the first place,
if we were just to start a new map.
By default, when you make an unreal level,
it won't have nav,
but all you have to do to create it
is if you go to volumes and go to nav mesh bounds volume.
And as soon as you create that,
you'll see you get this recast nav mesh.
This essentially is the runtime data
that represents your navigable space,
whereas it's the volumes that mark out areas
that should be navigable.
So if I drop that here,
you can see the nav mesh is being generated.
You can see the effect of hitting P here.
That's because I was already in show navigation mode.
So if you press P,
this is what it would be toggling on and off.
We get this kind of like data
about the nav mesh that have been generated.
We can see that mesh being generated.
And you can see,
if I were to just like expand this a little bit
or something like that,
that's going to marry up there.
And I can also just duplicate this bounds volume
if I want to say like,
this is navigable space and that.
And you'll notice that even though
I'm making multiple nav mesh bounds volumes,
I'm not getting more recast nav mesh data.
That's because this is our kind of like global idea
of our navigable space.
And the volumes represent each of the kind of spaces
that we want to demark as navigable space.
This is basically our paintbrush.
And then this is actually really the thing
that represents our runtime data
of the fully built up picture of all our navigable space.
And then there's, yeah,
once we've got this nav mesh,
there's a couple of different settings we can tweak on it.
So it's in the volumes again,
are just there to define areas
that should be considered for navigation.
And then it's up to the settings on our nav mesh,
on our recast nav mesh
to kind of define various things
about how that nav mesh is being generated.
So there's settings in here
such as being able to tweak our resolutions,
being able to tweak our agent radius.
We can tweak our cell sizes.
So if I were to put a block,
if I would just create, I don't know, a cone or something.
No idea where that cone just went.
Just going to try making that again.
Okay, I don't know why it's suddenly having an issue creating.
I'm going to try one more.
I'm just going to try a cube.
Okay, for some reason it likes cubes
and doesn't like cylinders.
So if I were to go to this nav mesh
and then I can go to my tile size.
Ah, I always forget exactly.
Tile size on real units.
Is that going to be right?
If I change that to like 50.
It's not in our bounds volume.
Yeah, it is in the recast nav mesh.
Oh, it's our cell sizes.
There we go.
Okay, so if I were to,
we could change our cell size from like 38 down to something like one.
And if I change that on all our settings,
you can see it regenerates the nav mesh
and we end up with a kind of more a kind of a nav mesh
that more closely mimics or matches our geometry.
Now obviously this is down to the fact
that there's a kind of gap between our cube here
is down to our agent radius.
The whole point is this recast nav mesh
is bound to a particular kind of agent
and therefore it's generating the space
that that kind of agent can navigate.
And therefore, because our agent radius is whatever it is,
35 by default,
this is going to be like a 35 centimeter gap between the,
or 35 unreal units,
which is essentially centimeters gap between the geometry.
So if I were to shrink that,
you'd see kind of more closely hugs the geometry.
And similarly again,
because this is all these nav mesh bounds volumes
are to say look everywhere.
You could possibly here to generate nav.
It's also generating it on top of spaces.
It doesn't necessarily mean they'll be able to get here.
There's no connection between these two islands,
but these are both treated as independently possible navigable space.
If I did want to connect this,
we can talk about nav proxy links,
which we can use in a little bit.
Or the other thing we could do is introduce a slope
to kind of be able to navigate up there,
because one of the things we can also define in this nav mesh
is our agent max slope.
And we can see if I were to,
for example,
duplicate that cube.
And you can see it's actually going to try
and I'm going to just scale this up a little bit.
You can see it starts generating mesh.
And now that I've kind of got an acceptable slope,
linking those two things,
it's made one coherent navigable space.
So that's how we create nav volumes.
It's worth looking through everything available
in your recast nav mesh
to see the different settings available.
If you're wondering why there are two recast nav meshes,
that's because I have two profiles set up
for different kind of agents.
We'll get to those profiles in a little bit.
But typically, if you just make a new project out of the box,
you would only see one
and it would probably be called recast nav mesh default.
I think that's the default agent profile name.
But yeah, it's worth looking at those recast nav mesh details
to kind of see what's adjustable there.
Oh, actually, just whilst we're on that,
one last thing that I should mention
is it's also in this nav mesh data
that you would be choosing
whether or not this data is static or dynamic.
So I think it's one of the settings right at the bottom.
You have a setting here, runtime generation.
So by default, this nav mesh is going to be static,
meaning it's not going to respond to runtime changes.
Whereas if you were to say dynamic on dynamic modifiers only,
we'll talk about nav modifiers in a little bit.
But dynamic is going to be,
this can respond to runtime changes
and dynamic modifiers only is going to be,
it's mostly static,
but specifically nav modifiers can have a dynamic impact on this nav mesh.
So that's a particularly important setting to be aware of
if you need dynamic navigable spaces,
you just know that that setting is there
and that's how you would change that.
And that is in the recast nav mesh data,
not the nav volumes.
Yep, so that's just kind of a little preview
of what a nav mesh might look like.
And again, similarly, you can see here,
because this has geometry
and because this geometry is marked up to affect navigation,
that's why it's carving out a volume,
this cube is either too far above the nav mesh
or it's not marked to affect navigation.
We can actually see that effect very quickly here.
If I were to do can affect,
you can see there's this tick box here.
This is going to be true of pretty much any primitive components.
So that's going to be box volumes, static meshes, anything like that.
It's going to have that setting.
And you can see as soon as I tick that off,
it's no longer considering this mesh.
It's going to generate navigable space underneath it.
It doesn't mean the actors won't collide with this geometry,
but certainly the navigation system
isn't going to consider it for ignoring,
take that into account when generating the navigable space.
So agent profiles, I kind of already mentioned,
but I'll just quickly show those off.
As we said, where by default,
there'll just be one profile set up for you.
But I believe if you go into your edit project settings
and into engine navigation system,
we have supported agents.
So again, if you have a game
where you need different kinds of entities
that can navigate the space in different ways,
that's a really good candidate for using multiple kinds of agents.
And you essentially would just create a new agent here,
give the agent a name,
and then you can just define settings about it.
So how, what would the default radius for this agent be?
What would the default height for this agent be?
Step height, so, you know,
if we're considering like a child versus an adult,
they might be able to treat different vertical differences in geometry
as kind of acceptable to navigate over.
And so this is a, you can define a height radius.
You can even define whether or not this particular agent can jump at all,
whether they can crouch, that can affect the nav generation.
And you can also create your own nav mesh classes.
So a particular agent can basically define a particular nav mesh data class
is used when creating the nav mesh for that agent.
So I've actually just in the C++ for this project,
I've just done a very simple example.
I've not actually done anything with it,
but I've just created a new class that inherits from recast nav mesh,
just to kind of show that you can do this.
That does require, if you were to do this,
you just need to bear in mind that in your build CS,
you do need to include the navigation system
because that's what will contain the nav mesh actor.
But if you create a separate class,
you can now choose a preferred nav mesh data that actor will use.
And again, I think as this says, you can also specify none,
and then it will just choose any nav data it doesn't mind.
And you can also say for this particular agent,
specifically generate a nav mesh using this class.
So that way you can have agents that require a particular class type
and other agents that can use nav mesh data of that type,
but also can tolerate multiple types.
And so when you create those different agents,
one thing to bear in mind is that if you don't have different settings,
if you don't either have like different agent height or different agent radius,
when you go to drag those volumes in,
you may not end up with multiple recast nav meshes.
So if you create different agents
and it seems like you're only ever getting one recast nav mesh data,
you actually need to make sure
that there are meaningful differences between your agents.
Otherwise Unreal will, I guess,
just infer that they're so similar that they can share a recast nav mesh data.
So just make sure that there are actually meaningful differences
between your agents,
such as different radius or different heights or something like that.
Otherwise you won't get multiple recast nav meshes.
And then for each of your bounds volumes,
you can then say,
is this bounds volume only for agents of a particular type?
So there will be a tick box
for each of the agent profiles that you've defined.
The default is that it supports all,
but if this nav mesh should only be generated for the common one
rather than the big one,
I can tick that off and you can see that gets regenerated.
And then that nav mesh data,
this whole area will only be navigable by agents using the common agent type
rather than the big agent type.
So that's kind of just another thing to be aware of
when we're dealing with agent profiles.
So nav link proxies, as I've mentioned,
give us a way to connect independent areas.
The kind of first example would be something like jumps.
It gives us a way to jump from a ledge back down to the rest of the graph,
but it also gives us a way to connect up a kind of isolated islands of space.
So if I were to have two spaces like this,
the way you would do this is there is an actor called a nav link proxy.
I can never remember if you can find it through the all tab.
If I go nav link proxy,
that's finding a blueprint that I've made.
Yeah, it doesn't for some reason, but there is probably another way to do this.
But you can also just go to your all,
and if I just search nav link proxy, you can find that here.
And then this is an actor.
This is essentially what a nav link is, is this actor.
So you would drag this round into world,
and essentially you just need to arrange this appropriately
such that it actually links these two bits of geometry.
So if I were to quickly demonstrate this,
in fact, what I'll do is I've got an example map.
We'll revisit this example map,
because it's demonstrating a couple of different things at once.
But if I just go to our example map,
we've got kind of two islands of space here, right?
We have these two navigable spaces.
And if I've kind of set up some stuff in the level blueprint
that essentially just says, when I press the three button,
order this AI to try and move to where this point is.
So if I just play and hit three, you can see it tries to get there,
but it doesn't get very far.
It gets to about here, it gets to the edge of its navigable space
before it's like, well, I just can't reach that point anymore.
I'm as close as I possibly can be, but I can't reach there.
So if we put in, I've got a pre-made nav proxy here.
If I just kind of snap this down to the floor,
you can see the nav mesh regenerates.
And that's because I've made a kind of like a link
between these two islands.
This is a specific actor that I've made,
but really this just inherits from nav link proxy.
I'll explain why I've made that nav link in a minute,
why I've made that actor in a second.
But just for now, you can see now that I've connected,
now that I've brought that nav link down
and kind of connected it up with the mesh,
it's now like treated as a kind of valid connection.
So if I were to kind of lift that up and away,
I don't know how close it has to be exactly,
but you can kind of see the arrow gets generated, right?
When it's close enough, when it's no longer close enough.
That's just hanging around now.
Um, if I just wanted to play, sorry,
just clicking the wrong things.
Yeah, you can see that that's, um,
for some reason, the debug arrow is kind of hanging around there,
but that's no longer navigable space.
And there's a certain point at which this is now kind of like,
and you can see the nav mesh reacting to it, right?
So it's too far away.
Won't be treated as kind of an acceptable link.
And once we're close enough, now it is.
So the way you work with a nav link proxy is you,
again, this is just an actor you can drag into the level.
You can make blueprints that inherit from it,
as you can see that I've done.
And then essentially it's just these two point links.
A nav link can also represent multiple links at one time.
So it's not just a one-to-one.
You can have a nav link that kind of represents a web of connections,
but by default, it's going to be just two points.
And it's got like a kind of left point and a right point,
and you essentially just manually author these points.
So you'll see, as I change these values, I've got this,
you can literally see the connection changing.
So you would just, if this is meant to represent a jump,
obviously you could just manually author this to be like,
have a certain amount of vertical transition between them.
And that's kind of all there is to it.
Then you can similarly mark up here, which agents is it suitable for?
How far should it project up and down?
So that's essentially going to be like, you know,
if it's a little bit above the nav mesh,
is it still going to try and find a nav mesh
within this much vertical distance that it can be a suitable link for?
And then also this idea that the, you know, is it a nav link?
Is it one directional?
So something like a jump,
obviously you shouldn't be able to navigate back upwards up that cliff.
It's kind of one directional.
So you can choose, is this a nav link that is suitable for both directions,
or is it left to right or right to left?
And I suspect we'll get an update in the arrow that kind of demonstrates that,
that it will kind of only work that one way.
Now, the other thing to mention about this,
and this is the kind of like reason I've made a blueprint here,
is we've got this kind of more complicated form of nav links,
of nav link proxies, which is called smart links.
So with simple nav links, with the kind of standard nav link,
that's kind of static data that is built in at edit time.
If we need something that is a little bit more nuanced,
a little bit more dynamic, that's where smart links come in.
Smart links basically give us the same capabilities of nav link,
they are part of the nav link proxy,
but they give us the ability to essentially turn this functionality on and off.
If a nav link proxy is utilizing,
because again, any nav link proxy actor you make is kind of both at the same time,
they've got the simple link and the smart link category.
If it is a smart link as well as a normal link,
then it will prefer to use the smart link
if they seem to have the same connections.
You can copy the kind of functionality of the basic points over to the smart link.
So you'll see they have these, when you look in the smart link section,
we've got like a link relative start and a link relative end.
This works in exactly the same way that our left and right do here.
But if you've authored a simple link, then you need to convert it to a smart link.
So if I change this connection a little bit here,
you'll see there's just this handy editor button
that essentially just copies that left and right data
into our link relative start and link relative end.
But otherwise, these do exactly the same job.
You can see as I tweak this,
you can see it's changing this second set of data,
and this represents the actual smart link, not the simple link.
So smart links, the same functionality here,
you can affect which directions it's for,
whether it's both, whether it's one way or the other.
You can check whether or not it's for a particular area, classes,
and then you can turn this link on and off.
So you can see as I turn that off, we get this different arrow color.
So this is no longer a usable link.
Obviously in this situation, because we've also got a setup here
for our default point links, then it's kind of both.
But if I were just to delete that, this is only a smart link.
This is not usable.
So our actor would simply not be able to use it.
And if I were to set that as enabled, now it can.
But this is also a change that you can make at runtime.
So if I were to, I can just get my smart link component
and just do set link enabled.
I can never remember the function name.
A set is enabled.
Might be valid.
Yeah, sorry, I lose the terms.
If I just look up smart link.
Okay, sorry, it's built into the nav proxy itself,
not the component, my apologies.
But either way, set smart link enabled.
This is the function on the nav link proxy itself.
And you can use that at runtime to toggle whether or not that's enabled.
So that's kind of one component of it.
But the other kind of useful thing to be aware of is once you're using smart links,
things can be notified that that smart link is either available or being used.
So one of the things I've done when working on games myself
is I've actually used this event that you can build into smart links,
this smart link reached to let us know when that link is being used.
So if I, you can see that we're getting a print string
when then the agent has started using that.
This same thing wouldn't happen if we weren't using a smart link.
So that's unique behavior provided by utilizing smart links.
And you could use that for kind of any number of useful bits of information.
You could play certain animations in this context.
In working in games previously, we've used it,
we essentially made door actors that were smart links.
And we got notified when the AI wanted to use this door,
we would kind of lock that door off so other actors couldn't use it,
so we couldn't have two actors passing through this door at once.
And then we would kind of enter a pre-canned door opening animation
to make the hand nicely marry up to the door handle and kind of navigate through that.
So that's an example of how, of kind of all the different capabilities
and power that these smart links provide us.
And then nav modifiers, we've already touched on this a little bit,
but just to actually kind of show you them being implemented.
Very simply, the easiest way to introduce nav modifiers is if we were to,
they can have an independent volume, so nav modifier volume here.
And you can see, this is just by putting it here,
this is kind of blocking off the geometry.
When you create a nav modifier volume, you get to choose an area class.
You can create your own here if you need to do something slightly different,
but by default we have a null, which is kind of, you know,
this, I'm blocking off this space as non-navigable,
but we can also do obstacle, which is essentially an area of high cost.
So what you'll see is if I were to put this nav modifier volume here,
when I tried to get my agent to navigate from here to this point,
it's actually going to kind of navigate around that space.
So if I were to kind of put this like this,
you see it kind of goes really far out of the way to kind of navigate around that space,
because we've marked this as high cost.
So nav modifier volumes just give you a very easy way
to introduce the idea of like high cost areas,
where the AI will choose if there's no other path.
It lets you define spaces that are completely non-navigable,
even though there is no kind of like other collision geometry that would block that.
And yeah, it gives us the kind of capacity to kind of change our nav mesh.
The other thing to kind of mention here,
we already talked about the idea of having possibly dynamic spaces, dynamic nav mesh.
So if I were to go to runtime, if I just move our nav modifier out here,
and I were to just play, and then I eject, and I find my nav modifier volume,
you'll just have to kind of trust me that it's there.
Unfortunately we don't get the editor handles when we're in play and editor mode.
If I were to snap that down to zero,
you can see that that's actually like carving out this space at runtime.
The reason that's working is because our nav mesh modifier
is set to dynamic modifiers only.
If I change this to static, and then I go to play again, same thing,
go to nav modifier volume, and I were to snap that to zero,
you'd see our nav mesh doesn't change.
And that's because it's now in static mode,
so it's kind of ignoring any dynamic changes.
So that is kind of a unique power given to nav modifiers,
is the fact that we have this kind of second or third state
for our nav mesh where we can be fully dynamic
and then obviously would pay attention to modifiers,
or we can ignore other kinds of actors,
only pay attention to nav modifiers,
so we're gaining some of the performance benefits.
We're not trying to consider every kind of actor,
but uniquely allow modifiers to change our mesh at runtime.
And then that's another kind of area where nav modifiers
and nav modifier volumes can kind of give us kind of extra functionality.
So on to the environmental query system
that we've talked a lot about kind of how we're able to navigate space.
But one of the kind of important things
when we're talking about querying things about the environment
is the ability to ascertain where we even might want to go, right?
A kind of typical thing that you might see in maybe a third person shooter
is you have an enemy who seeks out cover.
So we've got the navigation which can get us to that cover,
but how do we choose which cover to go to?
That's somewhere where our EQS, the environmental query system,
can kind of come in.
So the environmental query system allows AI to gather,
well, not just AI really, anything in the game,
and it is powerfully used by AI, but it isn't unique to AI.
It can actually be used in gameplay as well.
It's basically a way to query things about the environment,
to construct, to kind of ask questions about our environment,
construct a bunch of tests that say, you know,
I want to seek out the nearest suitable cover for this kind of enemy,
and then choose the location based off that query.
It's worth mentioning that whenever we're talking about EQS,
it is blocked behind a plugin,
so the environment query editor plugin.
I think when you start a new project,
usually this is enabled by default,
but just to kind of highlight that,
if we go to our plugins window and we do environment,
environment query editor,
again, I think it's typically on by default,
but just know that if some of this EQS functionality
doesn't seem to be available to you,
just make sure you've got this plugin enabled.
And then, yeah, essentially,
kind of fundamentally it lets us make these queries,
and we use a combination of generating points,
querying that, filtering and scoring
to give either the best result
or a couple of different options for either, you know,
randomly choosing from the best 25% or the best 5%,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Yeah, environmental queries can be called from Behavior Tree,
can also be called from C++,
and it can be run in Blueprint,
so it's not purely for AI,
it can also be used for gameplay.
I've used it previously,
for example, when generating points to spawn enemies at
or points where you might want to spawn drops,
maybe you don't want to spawn your drops
on top of any pre-existing enemies,
you could use an EQS to kind of evaluate that.
So the three key components that go into making up the EQS system
are generators, contexts, and tests.
Generators are essentially the thing, the first step,
the thing that we say,
the kind of fundamental makeup of an EQS query
is a carpet of points.
We essentially generate a carpet of points around our world.
It's the generator that's actually used to define
where should this carpet of points be,
how should they be laid out?
So we have a couple of different classes
available to us by default,
we can generate those points in a circle,
which is just, we define like a radius,
and then a, you know, degrees around,
or a kind of radians around, not even radians,
centimetres around the circumference of that circle.
We can do a grid where we specify essentially
a kind of 2D cube, a 2D square,
and we say every 50 centimetres wide
and every 10 centimetres in depth, generate a new point.
And then we have a donut,
which is a little bit similar to our circle,
but it's the idea that we might have multiple rings.
So we kind of generate in rows.
Yeah, we can talk about,
we can look at each of these kind of actually in the editor,
but we have a couple of different ways
of generating these points.
And they are essentially, again,
used to produce these locations
and it's this kind of carpet of points.
And it's then that carpet of points
that we perform the tests on
to actually give us our final result from the query.
And also, yeah, custom generators can be created
in Blueprint and C++
if circle, grid, donut aren't unsuitable to what we need.
Contexts are an important element.
The generators are what generate the points
and the tests are what test those points.
But the contexts are things that are used
at various points,
either within the generators or the tests.
They're a kind of frame of reference.
So you'll see as we kind of quickly diagnose
some pre-existing EQSs that I've made,
the kind of various points
at which we can use the various contexts,
but they kind of give us a frame of reference.
A context can return either a single entity or an array,
but it's just important to mention
that not all things that might be used in that context
are set up to handle a context that can return an array.
Some of them are only set up to handle a context
that returns a single item.
So a context might be the actor actually creating
the EQS query.
That would be kind of one of the standard query contexts
is querier, the person who is actually making this query.
Another example of a context might be
all the rooms in your dungeon.
You might create a custom context
that says, oh, use my room logic
to return an array of all the rooms in my dungeon.
And then I can use all the rooms in my dungeon
around the generator or the tests for various reasons.
So again, these contexts are kind of between the lines here.
The generators and the tests are the key points
and the context can be used in each of these situations.
And finally, we have the tests themselves,
which are actually used to determine
which these tests are going to basically run filters
and scoring on each of these points
that the generator has generated
to establish whether or not this particular
and an individual point should pass the test.
And if it does pass, if it does not get filtered out,
how should it be scored?
So if we were to, the easiest thing to do now
is actually just quickly jump into an example.
So if we go, this should be in your project
if you've downloaded that.
So in the EQS folder, we've got two different EQS's
that I've kind of made here.
So as we can see, I've made a donut
and this is just going to kind of generate
several rings of points around our context.
And as I mentioned, our center is defined as an actual,
this is where we would use our context.
So we have, our donut is using a custom context
that I've made, which is based off a target actor key,
so a blackboard key,
rather than the person who's asking the query.
This is intended to generate points around the person
who we want to attack, essentially.
So that's coming from a blackboard key
and that's what I've made a custom context for that.
And then we've got our two, these are our tests.
So our donut is going to generate around this particular context
and then that's going to generate based on what our donut says.
So we've got an inner radius and outer radius
and how many rings we need to generate.
So we're going to start at a radius of 100
and we're going to generate three rings between 100 and 200
and every ring is going to have eight points.
And this is, that's just our initial generation.
And then we're going to run these tests
on each of those points that we've generated.
So, you know, three lots of eights,
we're going to have 24 points.
First thing we're going to do is this path that exists test.
This is a pre-existing test that exists in the engine.
This is essentially say, can we nav to this point?
And then secondly, what is our distance from the point?
So as I said, tests can be either a test that filters points out
or it can be a test that scores them, or it can do both.
So in this situation, our path exists, purely filters them out.
It just says, if we can nav to this point,
if this point is on navigable space, then it would pass the filter.
If not, then it fails the filter.
And then this next test that we do is based off distance.
This hypothetically could filter points if it's too far or not far enough,
and it could score them.
But in the context of this distance 2D,
which is again another pre-existing filter,
I've chosen to score it only.
So I'm not going to filter any points using this test.
I'm only going to score them.
And I've said it should score based off 2D distance, not 3D distance.
So I don't want to care about verticality here.
And then I've just set some things about our scoring equations
so that this is essentially saying that if we think that distance from the querier
is going to go up, that number is going to get bigger.
So the default scoring is going to be further away is better.
So by inversing that scoring, I'm essentially saying closer is better.
So I want a point that is closer to our querier.
So a point that the querier being the person asking the EQS.
So in this context, it's the AI asking the question.
I want a point that is closer to the person actually making the query.
So we can see here how we've used generators.
That generator has used a context.
Our path exists test has also used a context here.
So the context here being that standard default context
of the person who is actually making the query.
So that's our AI.
And this is asking, you know, whether a path exists to the point from this thing.
And similarly, our distance, we've used the context again to say,
I want the distance from the person asking the question.
I could alternatively change the context to be our target actor.
And then this changes the meaning of this distance.
Then I'm asking what is the distance from the,
I want the point that is closest to the actual target.
Whereas this is saying I want to choose the point that is closest
to the person asking the question to myself, the AI.
So a kind of important thing to,
it's all good to talk about all of this in context in kind of like broad concepts.
But when we're working with this, the environmental query system,
obviously at some point it's helpful to actually see some of this stuff, right?
Because it all seems so abstract.
So one of the important things to remember is that there is a very,
very powerful Pawn that we can utilize to kind of visualize some of this stuff.
And that's the EQS testing Pawn.
The way to put one of these in your level is similar to our NavLink proxy.
I don't think you can just find it unfortunately through the normal place actors.
So there is probably some other way to navigate to it.
But the way I typically do that is just I go to all and then just search for EQS Pawn
and EQS testing Pawn comes up.
You can just drag this into your level.
And then this is just a Pawn.
You'll notice whenever you do that, you'll get a,
it will bring in its own AI controller.
So if you need to delete this, when you go to delete your EQS testing Pawn,
you'll get a complaint from your level because this EQS testing Pawn
is being possessed by this controller.
So if and when you do go to delete your EQS testing Pawn,
just be aware it brings in its own controller and you need to delete both.
But what you do with this Pawn is you essentially just say,
you give it an EQS to visualize, to test.
So you can choose from any of the EQS you've already made.
And you can see that this would essentially just generate this carpet of points.
Now this isn't going to be perfectly set up because this is relying on,
if we actually again, go and look at this, go and look at this thing.
It's actually, this context here is relying on this EQC target actor key.
So that this context is reading from a key from our blackboard,
which is relevant at runtime for this particular AI.
But in the context of in editor time, this might not always be suitable.
So it's worth kind of bearing that kind of stuff in mind
that when you're doing custom contexts, you need to be aware
that if you want to be able to debug this properly at editor time,
it might be worth kind of accounting for that
and adding in some kind of default behavior.
So if I were, the way I can kind of like actually do that,
I can just quickly demonstrate how we might do that,
is I will just quickly do query a blackboard.
But what I'll also do is if that value is for whatever reason null,
if I'll check if that is null,
you can see it defaulting to just say around the actor itself.
What I'll change this to is instead I'll do get all actors of class.
So this is the custom, this is the actual,
in custom context that I've made, this is the actor that represents that.
And you can see, not actor, sorry, the class that represents that.
And you can see it's got these two functions
for provide single actor and provide single location,
and similarly provide actors set and provide location set
if you want to return an array.
So I'm just going to get all actors of class,
and I'm just going to look for character,
and I'm just going to return the first character that we can find.
Better yet, actually my player here is represented by the BPAI player char.
So I'll just quickly hook that up and then get actor location.
Obviously this particular setup wouldn't work
if there isn't one of those in your level,
but this is just to demonstrate how you might handle this
in a way that kind of appropriately visualizes in editor.
One second, why is that not, is that actually finding the key?
Maybe I just need to reassign that.
Yeah, there we go.
So obviously we don't know that this would be the target,
but just to kind of give us a slightly better demonstration
of how this would actually visualize
if we don't seem to be finding this blackboard key on our blackboard,
which we won't because we're not at runtime,
so that blackboard key hasn't been assigned.
We're just going to fall back to finding,
trying to find a player in the level and getting the first one
and pretending that that acts location is our target.
So then that gives us a kind of slightly better visualization
of what this EQS is actually going to do
It's going to generate points around our target,
but then it's going to score our points
based off whether or not we can,
based on what is closest to the person making the query,
which in this case is the EQS testing porn.
And then we can also see what happens if we move our actor here.
We can see it's going to, maybe I need to refresh that.
You can see that filtering taking place.
So this is a kind of important thing to bear in mind
with the EQS testing porn is that these red nodes with zero
don't necessarily mean they're never going to be considered.
If you're doing an EQS query where every point is valid,
then this is still a valid point.
It's just getting a score of zero.
The only points that are actually getting filtered out
are these hard dark blue ones.
So the scoring mechanism goes from red to green
based off how high the score is.
The points that are hard getting filtered out by one of the filters
are this dark blue,
and rather than showing the score that they're receiving,
they'll print out a bit of text
to say which of these tests was actually filtering this point out.
And that brings us back to kind of one last thing to bear in mind
when you're kind of structuring these EQS queries
is that it's good to be doing your filters first, essentially.
If you can, going from like top to bottom,
if you're kind of putting your filters first,
that means that your scoring queries won't be trying to score items
that are never going to be considered
because a filter later is going to filter them out anyway.
So that's just kind of like a little thing to bear in mind
when you're making these.
But either way, you can see kind of by what's been demonstrated there
that that's just a way to make kind of intelligent decisions.
You can imagine this same thing.
As I said, I've done this for games in the past
where I've used this to query all enemies in your current room
and find a point that is,
and then score them based off, you know,
their distance from all of those enemies.
So you can find a point that is most likely
to not have an enemy currently overlapping it.
And that's where we should spawn our item chest, for example.
So you can use that in kind of gameplay context.
You can use it in AI contexts.
Yeah, we'll actually come to another example
from one of the Unreal templates in a little bit
where we're going to kind of stitch all this stuff together.